foreign
Centric Edition now obviously I love
Halloween I mean who doesn't uh and I
love horror anthologies which I think
I've mentioned on here a few times uh
and I especially love anthologies that
are based around my very favorite
holiday which is Halloween so I mean
I've seen and reviewed most of the best
ones like for I think I did a bunch of
them last Halloween like we did trick or
treat we did Tales of Halloween uh All
Hallows Eve like we've done a bunch of
the major ones but I actually came
across this 2020 movie called bad candy
that was streaming for free on 2B and
you know I thought I'd give it a whirl
uh though to be honest with you I didn't
even realize it was an anthology film
until I was about 10 or 15 minutes into
it and no I do not usually read the
synopsis before watching a movie why do
you ask uh honestly pretty much I was
just kind of like oh it's Halloween
themed all right and
I just you know went with it I didn't
like read anything else about it I also
didn't know before going in that the
film actually features uh the seemingly
ageless Zach Galligan of Gremlins and
waxwork fame and Corey Taylor of
Slipknot Fame now I am a fan of Gremlins
and wax work not so much of Slipknot
though
um but I have to say I kind of wish that
the two those two guys like their
characters roles were like bigger and
could have been expanded more
um because really they were just part of
the wraparound story and didn't really
like integrate into the Anthology
stories as a whole so it seemed very
much like a situation of these are the
two most famous people in the movie and
you know they shot their scenes in like
a day or two like in one single room you
know what I mean and you could
definitely like tell that they weren't
really like I said integrated into the
main plot so this was written and
directed by Scott B Hansen and Desiree
Connell uh this movie actually does have
some fun moments and at times it does
kind of like exude that a magical
Halloween Ambiance that we all look for
in our spooky October movies but I'm
gonna say unfortunately uh it doesn't
really come anywhere close to dethroning
trick-or-treat which is kind of like the
definitive Halloween Anthology film I
feel like and I don't think that I'll be
like re-watching this one because I do
kind of feel like a lot of Halloween
movies or Halloween anthologies I'll put
them in the rotation and like watch them
every year like in October and I don't
probably don't think I'm going to be
watching this one again it wasn't
terrible but it's a little bit like
messy and a little bit disjointed it
kind of had like some good ideas but a
lot of the ideas were really unfocused
and it doesn't really have any thematic
coherence I'm not saying that
necessarily like Anthology movies have
to do that but I kind of got the sense
that this Anthology in particular was
trying to have like some kind of like
thematic through line and it didn't
really do that very effectively which
I'll get into in a bit
um plus I have to admit too that I'm way
over uh scary clowns even before all of
the kind of like clown urban legends and
like it chapter one coming out and all
of that like brought them back into the
spotlight I thought they were kind of
played out because clouds aren't
necessarily all that scary to me so you
know that's another thing so Zach
Galligan plays a guy named Paul who is a
radio producer and Corey Taylor plays a
guy named Chilly Billy who is a DJ at
66.6 FM now in a framework that's
borrowed from another much better
Anthology film uh 2015's a Christmas
horror story in which the DJ was
unforgettably played by uh William
Shatner the DJs are doing a uh like a
radio show on Halloween night I think
it's called like psychotronic FM or
something like that and they're relating
a series of stories that we see
unfolding around this town which is
called New Salem now I have to say
though at first and maybe this is just
because I didn't realize that it was
going to be an anthology movie like when
I started watching it at first it wasn't
really all that clear to me that the two
guys on the radio were telling these
stories because it just seemed like it
was kind of just jumping it back and
forth from Paul and Chilly Billy in the
studio to other random people like doing
other random [ __ ] and I wasn't really
certain initially like what the story
lines had to do with one another like
maybe if I watched it again like knowing
that it was an anthology from the outset
like it would be clearer but because I
didn't know I was just kind of like well
wait what does this have to do with that
you know what I'm saying so it was that
kind of situation so anyway much like in
uh the Anthology film trick-or-treat
there's a character in the movie who is
kind of like an evil clown I'm saying
he's not evil but he's just like a
vengeful clown named bad candy though I
didn't know that that was his name until
the end credits uh whose job it is
evidently uh is to punish [ __ ] who
don't like Halloween or try to ruin
Halloween for everyone else by being
douches so one of the first people to
get it
um and rightfully so is this little
is this little preteen [ __ ] knuckle who
I mean despite having dressed up as a
vampire and going out trick-or-treating
is being like a real [ __ ] bag about
things he's just kind of like muttering
how everything sucks he's like smashing
everyone's pumpkins taking all the candy
from the house you know how some people
leave the candy bowls out and it's just
like hey just take one kid's like honor
System and he's just like dumps the
whole thing in his bag like an [ __ ]
like that kind of stuff
um I mean like if you hate it so much
just stay home and jerk off next year
like No One's Gonna cry you know what
I'm saying it's whatever so anyway
um it's a bad candy the clown uh picks
up this little brat and kind of like
extracts his soul kind of it's like he's
kind of sucking his soul out and he puts
it into this like cute little vampire
figurine that he then kind of puts in
his lair which is full of a bunch of
other tokens along those same lines I
thought this was actually like a really
cool idea like a Halloween demon who
traps [ __ ] into little tchotchkes as
punishment where they're you know
screaming in agony for eternity I'm on
board with that but unfortunately this
concept is never visited like in the
rest of the movie really and some of the
stories don't even have bad candy like
doing the Reckoning or the killing even
though I thought that that was going to
be like a through line that was going to
link all the stories together so anyway
the first of the tales is about uh like
a Halloween lovers club uh you know of
kids who has one member who's like a
little girl dressed as a witch I can't
remember if they said what her name was
uh but she has this kind of like abusive
redneck dad who at the beginning of the
movie like inexplicably like runs over a
guy in his truck like without realizing
it uh in this event is I don't think I
ever mentioned again which I thought was
very strange uh so this drunken hick for
whatever reason really really hates
Halloween and also
um as a sideline his daughter has a
power that everything she draws will
come to life so at one point she draws
like a fairy and she draws like this
cute Fierce little monster actually the
monster puppet is one of the best things
about the movie uh incidentally I kind
of wish that that little guy had been in
it more and I actually wouldn't mind
having like a little stuffed plush of it
because he was like super super cute but
yeah so she draws these they come to
life her fat showed of a dad destroys
them uh until the little girl like
finally draws her dead mom who like I
guess was like super Halloween was super
into Halloween which is maybe the reason
the dad hates it now or whatever but she
like appears all scary and pissed off
and sort of like slurps the dad's
innards out like through his eyeballs
and mouth and stuff in showers a very
very very dodgy looking CGI blood what
kind of I'll get back to that in a
little bit so there's also another story
about some like creepy old [ __ ] who puts
razors in candy bars and cupcakes to
give out to kids uh there's another one
about a drug dealer at a party who gets
killed in a disgusting public bathroom
by somebody wearing a devil mask there's
one about a lonely girl at that same
party who gets called into her work at
the morgue and has sex with like a fresh
corpse who she thinks is kind of
attractive uh which for some reason
makes all the other Corpses like zombify
and attacker although it's implied that
maybe it's the LSD that she took like
that she got from the aforementioned
drug dealer like earlier at the party
um there's one about yet another girl at
the party who's dressed like a cop who
gets assaulted and threatened by her
[ __ ] ex-boyfriend ex-friend so it's
stalker whatever uh until bad candy like
pulls him apart like uh fresh bread
which was actually like pretty
satisfying to watch uh and also one
about an Uber driver or a free ride
driver rather I guess they didn't get
permission to use Uber
um who's dressed like a vampire and he
goes around like collecting terrible
people he picks up like he doesn't like
not everybody like some of the people
are cool and he lets them go but he like
collects terrible people that he picks
up so that him and his group of like
military veteran buddies who were all
dressed like classic monsters oh and
plus one of them can turn into like a
bat creature type thing because of some
government experimentation when he was
in the service I guess uh but he
collects all these terrible they collect
all these terrible people and then they
essentially like haunt them for sport
because they're dicks so I mean some of
these stories were fine and entertaining
enough on their own and they did like
interconnect in a bunch of ways with
like some characters overlapping like
between the stories
um but like I said I thought the
repeating motif of the movie was gonna
be bad candy like the defender of the
holiday and he was gonna be like
gruesomely [ __ ] up people who were
being shitty to other people on
Halloween like in the first story like
with the little girl in the hillbilly
dad Bad Candy didn't I mean admittedly
didn't do the killing himself but he did
reward the little girl afterward for
[ __ ] his ass up by laying out this
big like epic like Halloween Tableau
like get putting all her decorations
back and like you know everything like
that and giving her like a bunch of
candy
um and also like the clown also warned
this one little girl like hey don't eat
the candy or the cupcakes from the nasty
old guy who put razor blades in he
doesn't talk but you know what I mean he
told her not to
um and then he went and [ __ ] up the
old guy and he also saved to the cop
costume woman from her [ __ ] rapist
friend he was like trying to you know he
was trying to get her but then there's a
bunch of bunch of like confusing [ __ ]
too like why did the drug dealer get
killed by some Rando that didn't have
anything to do with bad candy I was
under the impression that the punishment
angle was going to be kind of like the
connective tissue of the whole movie but
to be honest the drug dealer I mean he
was kind of like a little bit of a
sleaze but he didn't seem like that bad
of a guy
um although now that I'm thinking about
it like I guess he was giving people
free drugs on Halloween that would [ __ ]
them up like I guess hence another
meaning for bad candy I guess because he
was the one that gave drugs to like the
necrophiliac girl and like she started
seeing all the corpses like come get her
so I I don't know but that still doesn't
explain like why bad candy didn't get
him though like why did he just get
killed by this random guy who like cut
people's tongues out I didn't really get
that and really and the necrophile girl
while gross obviously was still kind of
portrayed sympathetically like she was
just lonely and like one girl one dude
that she had been really into like blew
her off like saying she was creepy and I
was like well what was the point of like
setting her up to be sympathetic it's
like oh all the dudes think I'm a creepy
girl and I can't get a date um and then
be like oh but she's a necrophiliac so
[ __ ] her I was like I don't know I
thought that was really weird
um you know she didn't really seem to be
hurting anybody like I said I'm not
saying like I'm not advocating
necrophilia because gross but I'm just
saying that she wasn't really hurting
anybody or like doing anything all that
dickish and honestly she took the drugs
but you know that was it wasn't really
all that bad so I didn't really feel
like she deserved what happened to her
and it didn't involve the clown anyway
um and the story about the four veterans
like hunting some of the [ __ ] from
earlier plus like a bunch of random
[ __ ] who hadn't appeared in the
movie before so who the hell are they
um that didn't really make sense either
because now they were the ones punishing
people instead of the clown and some of
the people who they were chasing down
didn't really seem to have done much of
anything bad although some of them were
and I was all on board with that but
like the rest people like wait who the
[ __ ] is that it's like what did they do
you know what I mean and then the last
story which was about a group of like
Ghost Hunters who kind of explore this
Haunted Mansion where a boy died in a
fire I think on Halloween some time ago
that actually like ties back in with the
frames story about Zach galligan's
character but by that point I had kind
of like tuned out a bit so I didn't
really like catch all the details now as
I said this isn't really a bad movie I
know it sounds like I'm [ __ ] on it
but it's it's not it's not that bad uh
there is some good stuff in here I did
like the hot the whole Halloween Avenger
angle and the interwoven stories idea
even though that's pretty much the same
thing that trick-or-treat did but I just
wish that it had been done with like a
more coherent structure I guess and like
more clearly defined parameters I mean
if you're gonna introduce Bad Candy as
like a recurring Motif like through all
the stories as a demon who punishes
people who are being dicks and also kind
of has this thing where he transfers
their souls into little Halloween
figures that's a cool idea like roll
with that don't just show that cool idea
one time and then like don't mention it
again and just like abandon it and I
mean like the stories could be pretty
much the same as they were just I feel
like bad candy should have been more
integrated into the action like in some
of the stories like the one with the
drug dealer the one with the necrophile
the one with the veterans I don't think
he even like showed up at all except
like maybe they drove past him in a car
and he was like standing there on the
side of the sign or something like that
so or he just came and like glowered
menacingly at somebody it just seemed a
little bit muddled like I said if you're
going to introduce that as connective
tissue then you know integrate it better
into like each of the stories because
all of these stories I mean it'd be
coming out a different like if you know
because some anthologies it's like their
whole thing is we had like all these
different directors which that's fine
like if you didn't have like a
connective tissue there but it did seem
like they were trying to do this in the
movie and this movie was actually
written by the same two people so you'd
think that it would like hang together
better and it just didn't on the plus
side though uh some of the creature
effects like I said the little monster
in the first part uh and the Practical
Gore were actually quite good especially
considering how low this movie's budget
obviously was
um honestly I kind of wish though that
they had done the whole thing with
practical effects because whenever they
use CGI it looks really bad like it
looks really cheap
um but I will say again on the positive
side uh some of the shots particularly
in the first story like about the little
witch girl in the Halloween lovers Club
were really really nicely lit and I've
had that spooky like old school
Halloween feel to them which I really
really dug
um I mean you know if you like it
Halloween anthologies and are looking
for like another one to check out that
you haven't seen yet I wouldn't
necessarily like warn you away from this
one but just don't like expect too much
and you actually might get a kick out of
it but if you've seen it like let me
know what you thought about it or tell
me like what your favorite Halloween
anthologies are I'm sure it's probably
trick-or-treat because that's
everybody's favorite because I mean not
gonna lie that is the best one so
that'll do it for this flickers of fear
thank you very much for watching and
I'll see you guys again on the next one
bye